hey guys my name is Jess McDonough it is
the 31st of July today and here watching
gamesbut news
first up Sony's game streaming service
PlayStation now has now launched in
public beta form Sony have released a
walkthrough video to get you up to speed
more than 100 games are currently
available through the service and you
can rent them for a bunch of different
durations which are associated with
different prices Sonya came to hear what
you guys think of the service in
preparation for its official release
down the line given that you guys are
still pretty miffed about the outrageous
pricing now is probably a good time to
tell them that I've come had a bit of
trouble sales wise this quarter thanks
to a lack of new major titles their net
sales stood at 93 million US dollars
down forty five point one percent from
last year although their operating
income was up seventy five point three
percent with an increase of 12 point two
million u.s. capcom have to thank Dead
Rising 3 for bringing in the cash since
its continued to sell well as well as
months to hunt a frontier GG which is
currently only available in Japan it's a
good thing game is still like killing a
shitload of zombies and giant monsters
well we're on the financial steam train
of success and happiness journey have
had a damn good time with their sales
from the last quarter Sony's game and
network services division which includes
PlayStation posted a profit of 41 point
eight million dollars u.s. that marks a
96 percent increase from the same period
last year which is obscenely impressive
Sony has said that the strong sales of
the ps4 alongside an increase in network
services revenues including PlayStation
Plus were big contributors to the strong
Vegas they also announced that 3.5
million ps3 and ps4 is combined with
ships during the quarter and 85 million
games were sold which is loathe ask me a
question of the day let me know down in
the comments if you reckon the
PlayStation now pricing is reasonable or
not and what you'd be willing to pay
those are all the things that I want to
tell you about today but be sure to
leave me your thoughts and catch me
again same time tomorrow of my top 5 of
the whole way